I got broken up like this I was in when
I was um when I was doing it was when I
was doing Sex in the City
and I was I really like this girl her
name was Bree I really liked her and and
I was doing I was in New York and I just
she was just like [ __ ] but she was I
don't know she was so beautiful
I met her doing a reading and I couldn't
believe she liked me and I'm doing the
damn thing I'm on set for two weeks Sex
in the City New York City and she's on
oh yeah and I and I got everything
planned cuz she's gonna come when I'm
done cheating I got a whole weekend
planned I got a whole [ __ ] weekend
tell you I got tickets to like different
Broadway shows High School I got [ __ ]
awesome reservations at the best
restaurants I got a even think I bought
some clothes I'm like this is gonna be a
sick weekend cuz this is gonna be the
weekend or she's in New York she's gonna
see my friends you're but I'm dating her
yeah like this is gonna be my girlfriend
yeah I was so pumped I was telling my
friends about our own pictures and and I
go I go hey I go up so I'm gonna get you
a take aces on the phone I'm gonna fire
first class I don't have money I didn't
have money I was gonna fire first class
I go I'm gonna fly you out and she was
can I could just call you back really
quickly I go okay so I go yeah yeah Loa
and she goes hey so I'm I'm not gonna
come in New York I go huh
and she goes oh yeah I don't want to do
this anymore
oh oh oh I'm sorry I'm sorry it's just
not there for me I guess she had met
this lawyer who was six foot six and who
was awesome and whatever it was it was
but I mean she my Jimmy Burke was there
Jimmy heard it lawful Jimmy heard it and
I was like oh okay well you know I
understand I guess thank you you know
look I liked you
it felt good to like somebody and all
right good doesn't mean he broke up with
me not so far yeah and Jimmy I turned to
Jimmy and Jimmy Burke is looking at me
and he's doing this he's going like this
he's got his [ __ ] lower lip out like
a baby's born mmm any minute he was I'm
sorry above it I was tough
and it is what it is I was so bothered I
was bottom rope and I was [ __ ] but I
told you the time I hurt my feelings I
was down I did this girl forever in high
school and I finally had to break up
whether my dad goes and we she was like
so sensitive she'd cry over everything I
told you my dad goes oh we to make it
easier on yourself I'm doing a public
place because then she doesn't feel like
I'm crazy
ah and so I took her to PF Changs in
Park Park Meadows to get a PF Changs
and we're sitting there and I was this
like waiting and she's like you alright
my camp good and I was like I'm gonna
order and then before the food comes I'm
gonna do it and it's my plan and we're
like you know just small talk and I go
hey listen I know like we've been
together for a while it's just not what
we're both going to call it this isn't
working and it's packed man and she goes
what she goes woo oh no she just scuse
me shows you're doing this here I don't
know am i clear and like no well yeah I
mean within she gets tears I go yeah so
embrace the way to come to you bailed
you bail though I'm not we're not
breaking I was just saying we should
talk about that I stayed with her for
another 60 you're damn right I go silent
[ __ ] terror why for six months than
her face that time that's crazy
whoa no I'm not a sticker out sticker
I'm saying I'm John it back what was six
months we revolt on that but have you
been broken up with oh yeah yeah that
was such a that was tough no because I
really liked her and I had like plans I
was like I'm gonna date this girl yeah I
liked it and I thought it was good the
sex everything I thought I thought was
good all of it was good could she
laughter it was a perfect relationship
she wasn't she was she was she was moved
on she's got you young too but the thing
I want right yeah I was yeah yeah well
yeah I remember in high school my coach
coach Weaver receivers code she was the
best call everyone slap dicks he's an
older coach and I had this serious
girlfriend and we were holding hands you
know going off to college
we're holding hands and she's all like
crying you know cuz the end of the year
his shop let me talk to you real quick
he goes
state your name stacy is go over there
it's never talked to us stop it stop it
quit being a slap dick here's what's
gonna happen this your girlfriend high
school usually go to college you can
[ __ ] a bunch of people get over it
don't make it all sad around the
hallways and [ __ ] you so right oh man
yeah you don't feel deeply when you're
young you feel [ __ ] what you think what
you don't you do have no perspective
perspective he's like hey this is it
this isn't one slap dick yeah this is a
heartbreak when you're young though cuz
I when I was in my head like insight and
[ __ ] my girlfriend broke up with me when
I was 18 and I was in college and I
realized it was over and she was in
Wesleyan and I was in shift so she was
in Connecticut I was in DC and I
realized it was really over your boy
cried alone outside because I couldn't
cry my dorm said roommate you boy cry
so hard that I thought I was gonna die I
remember looking up at the [ __ ] moon
its way to lying down crying oh you're
hardly your heart Oh John you have heart
disease I mean I really go bleeping are
we going breakup stories oh all [ __ ] on
your so you tell me that girl that I try
breaking up with at PF Changs and we
started working [ __ ] out so I'm sure
we'll probably get married
and then you know I'm I don't have much
money I'm going door-to-door sales like
pursuit of happiness I'm living with Jay
at the time we have like this place
she's living there too and I go to dude
I knew something was up we were a little
off I go to do Golden Gloves the boxing
tournament and it's over three days so I
passed the first round second round she
didn't come the first round
go set ground every way there shouldn't
come the second round finals it's a big
on the camel in the finals I'm like yo
where you actually
Oh we'll figure out finals I win I'm
with I'll never forget some with clop
we're driving home I get I'm like God
the house looks dark I walk in
everything's gone furniture TV
everything she wait for the right
opportunity to pack up all this [ __ ] I
don't have any money what were the
finals are going GlassBox off going goes
boxing she packed up everything she took
everything everything including the hour
dog moved out never heard from it since
I don't have anything what adding when I
had to do an eviction same girl though
or not different the PF Changs go what
she broke up with me she had a plan
that's crazy
Wow she's like drinking with laudanum
took all our [ __ ] TV it everything had
nothing that's a good time she left my
brother had his room so she left his
[ __ ] alone but all those stuff was I
cursed she had rich rich parents so they
bought us all stuff but she she knew I
was gonna be gone for whatever the four
hours of this boxing tournament
she got all truck every move all [ __ ]
out my girl when I broke up with her she
took all her furniture because she had
furnished our house tennis so she took
all of it including the bed I was still
sleeping Elia and the she goes we have
to get the bed and I go I'm still
sleeping she goes well we need the bed
and I turn into a major fight and she
opened the windows and started screaming
stop hitting me she said stop hitting me
stop hitting me screaming and then the
neighbors I went to run everything I
don't hit my girl they go we know we did
we don't we know you don't we knew we
knew that was [ __ ] I remember not
having to gave all the couches American
American Furniture Warehouse in Denver
sure and looking at couches and one was
$300 I can afford it there you go that
was a bummer three hugs
get on for 300 our couch yeah
tough gig that's uh that's what happens
when you're young and chasing your dream
you spent a lot of time who is no money
I'll tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]